some people don't know this but our own
Andy Richter does voiceover work for
cartoons and commercials and he's it's
quite good at it this is true right yeah
yeah I've been doing it for a while
yeah now the reason I bring it up is
because the other night I was up late
and I heard your voice I was in and I
was in the other room a nice brushed my
teeth the TV was on I heard your voice
on a commercial okay and then I came in
and I watched the commercial and it was
a little disturbing
yeah I'm gonna show it Rowe at Billy
you worked hard to illegally harvest
that kidney don't just put it into any
cooler the sno-cat kidney cooler is
specifically designed to keep human
kidneys fresh and viable until the buyer
meets your price snowpack kidney coolers
[Music]
can also hold soon
how was that no I well I can see how
you'd be upset I was freaked out there's
no question about that is that is
nothing sounded like me but that is not
me I swear wait are you sure it sounds
exactly like you well of course I mean I
would never do an ad for that that's
they got an Andy impersonator honestly
if you say so but what about this one
roll it bill a what one tired of your
job your family your house payments
reboot your life with a freak boating
accident calm will give you a new
identity with a new social security card
just buy a million-dollar insurance
policy and leave the rest to us free
floating accidents calm call today die
tomorrow
that was that und oh of course not I
need that again sound alike really
you say it's a sound-alike yeah I just
said that okay really play the rest of
the ad Billy free-floating accidents
comm works take it from me
Andy Richter Dan Walcott of Denver
Colorado
formerly Greg Moskowitz of Portland
Maine formerly Steve Ravello of
Clearwater Florida
all these aliases who the hell are you
Andy well gosh I guess the best answer
is someone you don't want to
[Laughter]
I'm just kidding come on seriously just
tell them who's on the show oh okay
start the new ABC series whiskey
Cavalier actor/comedian our good friend
vir das
[Applause]